you know traditionally
we all kind of perform alike yeah you
know even though and you have a real
different cadence
and structure
and because there is that comment if
people go to a comedy show in the in my
day used to talk about commercials and
airlines and things like but it was
always that if you didn't listen to what
they were saying there's also that
rhythm which i don't like anymore on you
know traditional sitcoms people are
talking like they don't talk in life so
when you hear something fresh and new it
really sticks out but again
people don't identify it as great at the
beginning i guess like your parents yeah
but the other comics did yeah other
comics knew it was different and that i
didn't waste any time you know when you
tell a story there's you can have five
minutes without a laugh and people are
still interested in the story but when
you're telling little one-liners you're
kidding me no
we just found out that norm macdonald
passed away
oh my god
i love norm mcdonald
he's young and there it goes
i don't know what to say me either
that was uh
breaking news but you'll know now when
you listen to this when uh when we
recorded it
oh i'm just uh heartbroken
i love norm norm is from my home country
canada and from my home club yuck yucks
and i've worked with him many times do
you know norm yeah we worked together on
uh last comic standing i took the job
because i wanted to work with norma
mcdonald and we fought every day you
fought with him we not not like
getting but we we would joke back and
forth with each other
and it just it took a little while for
us to gel you know that he would say
something and i would make fun of it and
he was like why is the why is the host
making fun of the judge
keenan uh keenan ivory wayans roseanne
we all like they were all like why is he
being mean to us and that was just the
way i did things right but i was uh
thrilled to be able to work with norma
donald and get to know him a little bit
uh huge huge influence on me of just if
you believe in the joke the audience
doesn't have to necessarily right
because you get it like his weekend
update was amazing legendary to me and
just one of the greatest of all time i
i'm i'm uh you know i i don't these
don't affect me that often but this is
uh this is a tough this is a this is a
what does it say i didn't read it what
did he die from
somebody in the control what did he pass
from it was cancer
he has he been sick cancer
nine years
he's had nine years of cancer i had no
idea i know he had like like a heart
surgery or something a lot of what
cancer of what he kept it a secret from
his family
and friends from what did he have cancer
of
we're looking at right now
oh my god not even his family knew i
wish i'd been nicer to him
nine years ago how many years ago did
you do last comic standing
it feels like yesterday it sucked so bad
but i want to say
2013 2012 maybe so yeah so he was he
already had cancer he was making his he
was making his comeback at that point
yeah
oh my gosh
norma had one of the funniest stories he
ever told on the tonight show about his
father do you know about his father and
bill cosby no no not his he told us on
the tonight show he told the story one
of my favorite stories because it's real
again
bill cosby was on snl when as a
guest host when norm was there and he
tells the story about
his dad got him into comedy norm
mcdonald's dad would sit him down every
time there was a comedian on the tonight
show or wherever he would sit him down
and make him watch and they would watch
cosby together cosby stand up and they
would laugh that was his father and him
bonding moment and maybe the reason he
got in the comedy so when cosby was on
the show he went up and he said mr cosby
you know i just want to tell you that uh
i think you're the reason i'm in comedy
you are my dad's favorite comedy
comedian and he used to make me sit down
in front of the tv and watch you and
that's what inspired me to go into
comedy but you're his favorite and cosby
says to him where you from and he goes
i'm from ottawa
canada and cosby says
i'm playing ottawa i'm on tour i'm going
to be playing ottawa in two weeks give
me your dad's number i'll call him and
i'll bring him to the show
and uh norm goes that's amazing
he goes what's his number and he wrote
down his number and then he walked away
and he started sweating and one of his
friends said to him what's wrong norm he
goes well i told him that story and then
once he said i'm going to call him i was
too uncomfortable telling my my father
died five years ago
so i wrote down i just wrote down a
[ __ ] number and that's it they go
how could you do that norm two weeks
goes by norm is sitting in his office
they get a call they said uh norm bill
cosby is on line two
this is two weeks later and he picks up
the phone and he goes yeah he goes
listen i'm in ottawa and your dad's not
answering they said that this number is
disconnected that you gave me what is
his number and i can't remember for the
life of me the end of the story but norm
was stuck on the phone and he didn't
want to say oh yeah i forgot to tell you
that he's dead like at what point do you
kind of break this to bill cosby it was
one of the funniest real
uncomfortable and that kind of comedy is
the kind of comedy that i when people
are uncomfortable and when norm mcdonald
told that real life story it's really
funny but oh my god his father's dead
you know it's like you get out of that
yeah yeah there was no way is there an
ending
i can't remember the ending and i wasn't
prepared for this story and i haven't i
remember i hear it a lot i'm just kind
of bowled over by the loss of somebody
younger than me too i was at my no my
that made me think of an mcdonald's
story he had told about having rodney
dangerfield on snl he was just going to
come into a weekend update a little bit
about not getting respect
and norm had an assistant who just had
one joke he told it's an off-color joke
i'll tell it anyway he said hey
a uh a gay guy goes to his roommate
he says hey
i'm gonna hide
and if you can find me
i'll suck your dick
and he goes what if i can't find you and
he goes i'll be behind the couch
and he told that to everyone and he has
these assistants like tell rodney the
joke he tells rodney the joke and ronnie
doesn't laugh at all and he goes i got
to tell you kid i'm not much for jokes
and norm thought that was the rodney
dangerfield like mr joke i know it would
be like i'm not much for jokes i love
that yeah i love that
i love that i love the stories i cannot
believe 61.
so young but he's been sick for nine
years and nobody knew
right see this is a well-oiled machine
no i listen i'd say no to podcast all
the time i would not be here if i didn't
uh respect the hell out of you and uh
you know of course well that means well
and uh and and want to do this i i just
can't believe i came here to to find out
norm mcdonald died like that's oh my god
that's that's a gut punch it really is a
gut punch and it kind of i'll be totally
honest with you it is a gut punch that
kind of
brought my mood down because you know he
is somebody and
even doubly because
to not know that he was sick i i feel
like i would have wanted to be there
for him or at least but maybe that he
it's his choice
yeah i mean he talked about death a lot
and that i'm sure he he went out the way
that he wanted to
uh i i'm thinking about the [ __ ] in
the booth over there who were like let's
flash this on the screen during a
podcast yeah who was the [ __ ] that
was rich
was
alex
yeah no we thought you might want to
talk about it or get it up like this
week because it means a lot to the
comedy world yeah
surprise us with that yeah and uh
let us react in real time that's great
oh my god it that is a gut punch um
we love you uh
norm we love your comedy he was a good
human being he was uh
somebody that uh i think we're all gonna
miss
100 i mean one of the greatest of all
time and he really is only like
solidifies his legacy i think that
people really will i thought he was
really treated unfairly at snl when he
was fired there was no reason to fire
him i mean i i think he pushed the
buttons that he knew that if he kept
doing this he was gonna get fired it was
all the oj jokes um but i think he went
out in his own terms and i think that's
kind of what made him a legend you know
the fact that he never had the huge hit
sitcom he didn't become seinfeld i think
added to his legend that i think he had
an amazing career and his comedy output
is uh is unparalleled that he'll never
be forgotten